hey i don't want to dive into the ti
thing because you've talked about it to
the death but i just i never remember
the initial just kind of conflict like
what what did it what was the
origin of of it it was some petty stuff
like me and him we actually have each
other number um we probably text and uh
yeah we talked about me coming on his
podcast and him coming on mine
so we go we go together that would be
dope yeah yeah so we we go scheduling
where we're filming both at the same
time so we talked we had dialogue on it
but
what i will say like it was really super
petty and it was something that i tried
to
nip in the bud before it spiraled out of
control you know i mean because you know
i know how right things can get out of
hand so
i'm just glad that jay prince being the
og that he is
decided to step in and say you know what
like i i can't let two youngsters you
know what i'm saying young cats from the
south yeah two kings
and at the end of the day
we both talked about it laughed about it
and he was like
yeah he was like man we was kids we so
you know it's out to the g but it was
petty and um i've moved past it man it's
beautiful man yeah